my name is laurens van den Acker on the  head of design of the Renault group and  this here is the rental car the design  of the car is very athletic very sporty  and it is extremely sensual and this is  very new in this segment Kjar comes in  nine colors this combination of beauty  and practicality is what's the key of  the success of the crossover so you have  a great trunk and the looks that makes  you go on an adventure so it's the best  of both worlds katia has been a position  itself on the upper segment of the  crossover which we call the c-segment  kaja will be built in Spain it will  start to be sold in Europe starting in  summer 2015 and at the beginning of 2016  it will be the first car to be produced  in China in the new plant which is being  built wuhan how many do you hope to sell  Oh many